Speaker 1: Donald Trump has hit a humiliating
seven year low in polling as Joe Biden is seeing
his approval rating climb since the 2022 midterms.
There's really interesting dynamics developing
in national politics. This is not about the 2020.
For election. This is about how it is interesting
to think historically of circumstances in which
current or out of office elected officials see
dramatic changes in approval rating. And to
understand what precipitates that. So let's
start with the news. CNBC reports Trump hit a
seven year low in the new national poll as Biden
approval climbs about a month after launching his
24 campaign. Trump's standing with voters has hit
its lowest point in more than seven years.
This is according to a Quinnipiac University
poll released yesterday. Only 31% of registered
voters surveyed hold a favorable view of Trump
versus 59 unfavorable. That's the lowest rating
Trump has received since July 2015, shortly after
he launched his first presidential bid. So two
ways to interpret that. One historic low and
Trump is going down in flames. Counterpoint This
is as bad as it was for Trump when he started
running in 2015 and he ended up being president
of the United States. So maybe we shouldn't
write it off. Meanwhile, what about Joe Biden?
Joe Biden's approval rating still underwater,
is at its highest rating since September of 2021.
Just 43% of respondents say they approve of Biden.
49 disapprove. But that is a significant increase
from last month. And Biden has not yet announced
that he's running in 2024. But it is increasingly
looking that way. And so Trump down. Biden up. So.
Check out this list of ideas about how someone can
raise their approval rating. And I think you'll
very quickly see why it may be a problem for
Donald Trump. Effective leadership, people seeing
you as doing effective leadership. Trump's not
in office. So that's going to be really difficult
handling important issues. Well, Trump's not
in office, so it's going to be hard to do that.
These are ways that people in power can raise
approval rating. Good communication skills. Well,
sure. I mean, I guess if Trump somehow became
good at communicating, that would be useful of
being responsive to constituents. Trump doesn't
care about constituents. That's hilarious.
Economic performance. Trump's not in power, so it
would be hard to do that. So given that Trump is
not in office, what can elected officials out of
office do to raise their approval rating? Okay,
stay visible and engage with the public.
Even if you're not in public office,
you can become visible and engaged by doing public
events, media appearances, speeches, rallies,
etc.. Well, Fox News and many other prominent
media don't seem to want to interview Donald
Trump, and it's not totally clear how quickly
he is going to go back to rallies. But I guess
potentially holding rallies might be something
Trump can do, although having 4000 people go
to see you speak, I don't know if that's really
going to move the needle nationally. Secondly,
Trump can be vocal on important issues,
even if he's not the one handling them.
He can speak out about issues facing the
country. Trump could do that, except mostly
when he gets the opportunity to speak. The
issues are the 2020 election was rigged.
We have a problem with men in women's sports,
as he likes to say it. And the country is now
communist. Not exactly the type of stuff that's
going to raise your approval rating. And then
lastly, Trump can build a strong team that
inspires confidence. And there are rumors Trump
might soon announce who would be his VP. I don't
know if he's going to do that. We'll see. But
often it seems as though Trump's team is getting
worse and that right now it's a very ragtag, low
end team, even compared to what he had in 2016 and
2020. The additional problem Trump has right now
is that there is a significant faction of the
Republican Party that's preemptively breaking
away for Ron DeSantis, even though Ron DeSantis
hasn't announced that he's running for anything
yet. So it's going to be tough. It's not looking
great for Donald Trump. But I think the important
thing is if Trump does get the nomination, the
people that break away for DeSantis mostly will
fall in line and vote for Trump because they
hate Democrats way more than they dislike Trump